we begin this morning with the reopening
of the federal government President
Trump and Congress reached an agreement
last night to end the 35 day partial
government shutdown for at least three
weeks the deal provides a window until
mid-february for negotiations on border
security it also means that more than
three-quarters of a million federal
workers will get paid for the first time
in more than a month
Nikole Killion is at the White House
with the latest Nicole good morning good
morning to you Anthony and late last
night President Trump signed that bill
to reopen the federal government but it
doesn't include money for the border
wall and some Republicans are
criticizing the move as a concession to
Democrats but in a tweet the president
denied he caved in we have reached a
deal to end the shutdown and reopen the
federal government the longest
government shutdown in history came to a
close yesterday after President Trump
agreed to fund the government for the
next three weeks while Congress
continues negotiations on border
security it came on the day that many of
the 800,000 furloughed federal workers
missed their second paycheck and
airports around the country experienced
flight delays due to sick outs by air
traffic controllers working without pay
I want to thank all of the incredible
federal workers and their amazing
families who have shown such
extraordinary devotion in the face of
this recent hardship the administration
had been criticized for minimizing the
toll the shutdown has had on federal
workers at a Washington Food Bank they
welcomed the news it's about time I hope
it's a little more sustainable than
three weeks this for you means what my
family will be able to pay our bills and
we'll be able to you know be off the
street and stop begging for food last
night House Speaker Nancy Pelosi signed
the continuing resolution after the
House and Senate voted unanimously to
reopen the government Democrats are
committed to border security and we
think we have some better ideas about
how to do so that protect our border
honor our values and our cost effective
negotiations will continue until mid
February but unless a deal is reached
between lawmakers over funding for a
border wall the threat of another
government shutdown remains if we don't
get a fair deal from Congress the
government will either shut down on
February 15th again or I will use the
powers afforded to me under the laws and
the Constitution of the United States to
address this emergency Democratic
leaders have been emphatic that they
won't give the president a penny to
build the wall in the meantime the
president's State of the Union speech is
up in the air it was supposed to happen
this coming Tuesday but now speaker
Pelosi says that she will work with the
President on a mutually agreeable date
Michele mark your calendars thank you
Nicole